Speaker 1: Let's take a look at the
continued downfall of Ron DeSantis,
the Republican Florida governor who is polling
about 20% in the Republican primary, more than
everybody but Trump, but with seemingly no path
to actually securing the Republican nomination.
Ron DeSantis was interviewed by Fox News's Stuart
Varney or Fox Business's Stuart Varney. This is a
Kafka esque moment. I apologize. I apologize.
It is Kafkaesque. Stuart Varney mentions two
dissenters. Listen, you're down over 30. How are
you going to catch up? What's your strategy? And
DeSantis just attacks the media. I don't know
that this strategy has winner written all over it.
Speaker 2: You're down.
Speaker 1: Over 30.
Speaker 4: Points to Trump.
Speaker 2: What's your strategy for catching up?
Well, first, I think it's pretty clear that the
media does not want me to be the candidate. I
think that they've tried to create a narrative
that somehow the race is over. This is going to be
a state by state contest. We've worked really hard
to build tons of organization in places like Iowa,
New Hampshire, South Carolina, that you need to
actually be able to win these early contests. And
we're going to continue doing that. We've got a
lot of work, but we've had very, very favorable
response and we're going to keep building off that
momentum at the end of the day. I think the fact
that I'm the one that's targeted by the media,
by the left, even by the president of Mexico.
Speaker 1: Listen, if the strategy is I'm going
to pretend to be a victim just like Trump,
it pretends to be a victim. I guess
he's doing it. But I don't know that
this is going to get him too many votes.
Speaker 2: Because people know that I
will beat Biden and they know that I will
actually deliver on all these issues and
beat the Democrats at the border. Beat up folks.
Speaker 1: This is really low energy. You're down
32. TRUMP What's your strategy for catching
up? Well, it's mostly the media's fault,
but I'm going to beat Biden. Well, you're not even
going to face Biden unless you figure out a way to
make up a 30 point gap on Donald Trump. If I want
to be as charitable as possible to Ron DeSantis,
he seems to be saying when he says it's a state by
state contest. 30 points nationally don't matter.
If I can win Iowa and or New Hampshire and justify
staying in this race, it's not looking like he can
win Iowa or New Hampshire. But let's put that
aside if I want to generously say that's his
strategy. Okay. I guess that's a strategy, which
is forget about the national polling. Just focus
on those critical states. During this disastrous
interview, Stuart Varney actually asks DeSantis,
is there is there any climate plan
that you have? Listen to what he says.
Speaker 2: The headlines are just full of stories
about wildfires, smoke, extraordinary temperatures
in the southwest and the southeast to some degree.
Do you have a climate plan? It's going to be to
rip up Joe Biden's Green New Deal. I think at
the end of the day, we need to embrace American
domestic energy. This could be a huge source
of national security, economic vitality. It can
build our industrial base in Florida. We've
actually had a huge reduction in emissions,
but it was done through innovation. It was done
through market forces, not command and control. So
we'll go about that in a much different direction.
Speaker 1: Now, you might be surprised
about hearing that he's going to do away with Joe
Biden's Green New Deal. And the reason you might
be surprised is there is no Green New Deal. Now,
if you press them on this and you say the Green
New Deal isn't the law. What do they say? They
usually say something like, well, Joe Biden has
integrated elements of the Green New Deal into the
Inflation Reduction Act as well as by executive
order. But then if you really press them, it's
very difficult to actually make that a believable,
believable argument. So as I've said before,
not ready for primetime does not have winner
written all over him, has absolutely no tangible
explanation as to how he's going to make up the
30 point deficit. And he's only running against
Joe Biden. And the funny thing is, he's running
against Joe Biden and against things Joe Biden
hasn't actually done. You've got to figure out
a way to win one state here, bro. And it's not
clear that he's figured that out. And meanwhile,
there are problems in Florida. Trouble
in paradise. Let's talk about that next.